[Music]
you're likely gonna have to give a
speech so you better do something about
this I don't know what to do I really
don't know what to do I should get some
of that there's toothpaste for a dry
mouth but I don't know if there's some
this is a really attractive conversation
we're having it's okay but here's right
here's here's the big thing I want to
know you have to go to work tomorrow
even if you win or not yeah I do I have
a table reading at 10:00 in the morning
whether I win or not it is kind of but
you know what I kind of love in some way
that I have something to do tomorrow no
matter what it's it's they all love me
there and they will love me no matter
what happens and I get to go to work and
Patti LuPone is going to be on our show
so I get to be with her tomorrow so I
hope if you win you bring the Oscar to
work right oh I will probably if I win I
would go right from parties to work I
would not I don't know right now I know
you recently met William and Kate's I
did so what you learned from that
encounter I didn't know Kate was so tall
she's my height yeah I mean I've granted
I didn't have my shoes on when I met her
which was another thing that I had to
admit by the way I yeah you don't meet
royalty with your shoes on but they're
pretty relaxed and cool I just broke the
rule because I'm with royalty meeting
you Oscar royalty and look at what I've
done I love you I'm gonna be there in
five minutes
yeah yes did they invite you to the
wedding
the upcoming wedding where they like
come on Elsa come on surprise but no
invitation yet I thought I made a good
impression on them but nothing yet but
now heavy have you spoken a time yet
this award season you know yes I mean
she texted me today I just saw as I was
coming down the carpet and then I got
pulled so I was like I Tania texted me
just a minute ago so what she said I
don't know I was looking for my phone
this is not going to be the first way on
if you end tonight all or season because
you've pretty much swept all the award
season
what has time you've been saying all
along to you oh she's just been so
supportive and loving of me and she
sends me texts to say go get him girl
and yeah she's pretty great I totally